carlos is with us Carlos is in
Indianapolis hi Carlos how are you hi
good how are you David
better than I deserve sir how can I help
thank you so much I am actually
facilitating the course in Spanish you
know the others with your Spanish
version of Financial Peace University
and it's an incredible pleasure to do
that well thank you Andres is a
wonderful teacher I'm glad you're doing
that he does a great job and the
question that I need to make sure that I
that I know how to answer it has to do
with investments and 401k plans or
mutual funds especially with respect to
the the scenarios that are given that
are kind of using a pretty high level of
interest you know accumulation and you
know I know my own investments have not
done well in the past couple of years so
what are we saying nowadays what kind of
return can we you know expect to to get
in the long term of course these these
investments are a long term but not
seeing the same level of our returns
we've seen before well in some of the
markets down you would say that you're
not seeing the same level of returns as
you've seen before um the way you're
phrasing that it sounds like you think
that that's the projection into the
future I don't know that I don't know
that it's bad in the future or good in
the future I mean if you go back for
instance in time prior to say into the
early 90s you would have said the same
thing you would have said huh these
returns have been lackadaisical oh it's
been awful it's been a hard time and
then all of a sudden you get a zum-zum
decade yep and that throw the averages
all up and then you know since that
decades over you roll into 2008 and it
goes in the toilet right it's just
horrible
I mean it's the worst downturn in the
markets history or one of the worst
downturns in the markets history and
just horrendous times and you know that
throws the numbers off and then we come
back and we're you know we're back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth and these current returns are
screwed up more by oil than anything
else you know oil stocks are down
because all profits are down in general
other companies are making money but the
oil stocks are dragging the rest of the
the
averages down if you're looking at the
across that and that's what we're
sitting in the middle of right now but
what I'm looking at is if I look at a
growth stock mutual fund in my 401k
my personal 401k and I and I look at the
average annual return over the history
of that fund and that fund is 50 years
old or 80 years old or 40 years old and
I look at that average that's the
average I'm going to use it's not that
far off of what's in those returns in
those videos you can find that now again
you know if you want to shorten up your
return window that you're looking at you
can create all kinds of scenarios that
would demand that that you project lower
and if you personally think there's a
black cloud over the future then you
would project lower these are examples
they're not guarantees they're examples
of what the market has done and really
what I want to do and what you want to
do and what undress wants to do more
than anything is to teach people to
think not to teach not to tell them just
do this blindly because you said do it
or I said do it but teach them to think
my personal portfolio has done about
what you know we project on those things
and I've had some years it did a whole
lot better and then I've had some years
it did a whole lot worse but you know my
personal portfolios outperform the S&P
500 and I'm not a rocket scientist I
mean you can pick mutual funds in the
average 401k if you look they can
outperform the S&P and that's what
you're looking to do if you did that
over the last decade because you've got
2008 in the last decade I mean you'd be
down around 9% after fees but if you
reach back that as the last decade or
you don't have that 2008 see
statistically I mean you know numbers
work I can tell by talking to you
statistically if you just take a big
chunk out of the numbers with a huge
downturn like 2008 it takes an amazing
shoot up in the market just to keep the
averages where they were yeah and so any
you know the only way to smooth the
thing
out is to go longer with your go longer
into the history to get a more accurate
view I think but if you say well the
future is not it's there's just all
these things there's all these problems
well there's always been all these
problems I mean at any point in history
you look there was something to make us
worry and think that the future wasn't
right I don't know what the future is
going to hold I don't know I make my
choices on mutual funds based on their
past history but I don't know that
that's going to be the future I make my
choices when I buy a piece of real
estate based on the quality of the
neighborhood but I don't know that
they're not going to move a toxic-waste
warehouse in next door I don't know that
I can't be sure of what's going to go on
all I know is what I've got to look at
when I'm buying that particular piece of
property and there's no guarantee when I
buy that piece of real estate but I
bought it in a good neighborhood there's
nice big trees and people seem to be
using their weed eaters and you know I
believe we're going to be in good shape
here and you know nobody's got the car
up on blocks in the front yard and
trying to plant stuff in it or something
and so that's a good neighborhood and
I'm going to be okay with that and but
it could change I mean the neighborhood
I grew up in has changed it's um
you know a lot of you you look back at
the old neighborhood and I mean I
thought I didn't think anything about at
the time but it can turn into the hood
over time you know what I'm saying and
so you just got to watch what you're
doing in the same things true the mutual
fund what neighborhood is it in and how
do I feel about the future and the
prospects of that but I'm not going to
completely condemn the stock market as
an investment vehicle based on what it's
done since December based on what it did
in 2008 and if you don't want to use a
12 percent number using 8 percent number
use a 5 percent number I don't care but
you ought to base it somewhat on logic
and logic would be looking at the past
over a long period of time and looking
at a particular fund over a long period
of time and that's logical and that's
reasonable and Carlos if you if you go
on the internet you will find a lot of
people criticize me over this so but
they don't understand they say I'm you
know like I'm somehow guaranteeing
someone a 12 percent rate of it
I'm not I've been able to make more than
that but I'm not and I'm not a rocket
scientist I'm really not but you know
maybe you can't maybe you haven't been
able to find a fund that does that so
you need to use your brain when this is
your message to your class Carlos you
need to say to them use your brain
learn how this works and pick good funds
pick good things that have a good
history just like you pick out a home in
a good neighborhood that's the point
we're teaching people to think you don't
want people blindly following anyone's
financial theory or idea they need to
learn and they need to think and then
that lines you up to win long-term
really good question thanks for bringing
that up
I appreciate it this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim
you